okay in this video we're going to be
covering the third mode that I use in
Indian
clubs if you haven't already done so
check out the previous two modes in the
description
below so we're going to look at split
time opposite
direction in the previous tutorial when
we went up and down um in opposite
directions in this one we're going to go
from side to side in opposite directions
so one goes up one goes down and then
the meet at the other
side remember you keep points with this
you've got your left and your right and
up and down your hands should cross at
left and right and be at opposites at
top and bottom essentially with this all
you're doing is moving your hands up and
down and then turning with your waist
side to side that's what creates a
circle with your
arms so once you're comfortable hitting
the four key points the movements can be
smoothed
out here I'm going inwards with both
arms obviously the same can be done in
the opposite
direction so reversing the direction
still hitting those four key points this
is moving your arms outwards split time
opposite
direction so with the clubs we're going
to do the same thing make sure that
we're hitting the four key
points make sure your arms are
extended clubs should pass at the sides
and should be at opposites top and
[Music]
bottom once you're happy with that
movement try smooth it
out so here I'm doing it with two
semicircles just meeting at either side
and then now I'm just doing one
continuous
Circle to learn this movement it'll help
pick a key Point as a marker and
returning back to
it this helps get the timing right so as
always there's an opposite direction
doing the same
thing in Reverse now going outwards so
whereas before both hands were going
inwards this time they're going
[Music]
outwards so we'll have a look at a
couple of common mistakes and things to
avoid one of the things is going too
fast and getting ahead of yourself as
you can see here it will just end up in
some crazy swimming
motion this can also happen if you don't
turn off from the waist which you can
see in the second clip my arms are also
not hitting the key points
and everything's out of
time if you find this is happening go
back to the four key
points make sure your arms and body are
coordinated and moving together in the
correct
time so now we'll have a look at split
time Inward and outward Mills so using
the same idea of reels like in the
previous variations we'll put them
together so just as one is going up the
other is going
down so here I'm starting the outward
Reel with my right hand just as I'm
about to do the downward swing with my
right hand that I bring my left hand up
the positions will alternate so as left
goes down the right comes
[Music]
up so looking at the same thing from a
different aspect doing the same
movements as what we did at the start of
the video whereas the difference here
the arm that's going upwards is
reeling the movement I'm doing here are
outward
rails so let's take a look at that going
the opposite direction doing inward
rails so going inwards now it'll be the
opposite hand that's going upwards and
doing the Reel at the
top you still want to make sure you're
meeting all four key
points once you happy with that movement
you can start to smooth it
[Music]
out and then try not stopping at the key
points but just be aware when
transitioning
through
okay well that's it for this video the
next one will be on split Time same
direction it's the last one in this
series of four basic
modes thanks again for
watching